et pendant ce temps-là paris une
cinquantaine de chômeurs continue
d'occuper normale sup soutenu par autant
d'étudiants et puis occupation surprise
d'une autre grande école des chômeurs
dans l'amphithéâtre de sciences po
reportage damien thévenot et françois
granier interdit de départ le rendez
vous était fixé devant l'école normale
occupé depuis mercredi par une
quarantaine de chômeurs rassemblement
pacifique à l'appel d'associations 200
emplois auxquels s'étaient joints des
intellectuels un événement exception
historique très rapidement les
manifestants ont décidé une action
surprise
comme toujours le lieu gardé secret
jusqu'au dernier moment pour devancer la
police cet après midi ces sciences po
que les chômeurs ont choisi d'investir
en force
finalement une cinquantaine de chômeurs
ont pu pénétrer à l'intérieur du
bâtiment discussions et débats
improvisés entre futurs énarques et sans
emploi ont recoupé france avait deux
mois pour manger maintenant je vais vous
parie papier enfin je comprends comment
d'avoir mais j'arrive pas à penser une
solution d'accord ou pas en tout cas les
étudiants ont apprécié l'initiative des
chômeurs c'est prouvé dès la réalité les
choses et c'est bien ce soir
les chômeurs vont passer la nuit à
sciences po prêt pour la grande
manifestation prévue demain
après les actions spontanées des
chômeurs vient maintenant l'heure de la
stratégie stratégie organisée par les
associations qui dirige le mouvement
avec notamment à leur tête claire
villiers une militante chevronnée qui
est devenu l'une des interlocutrices des
pouvoirs publics olivier caroff
dominique bonnet chez moi sécurité il ya
les jambières et paul temps dira ali
à un emploi du temps de ministre pour
celle qui depuis un mois empêche
justement certains ministres de dormi à
47 ans claire villiers fait partie des
principaux responsables du mouvement des
chômeurs en colère c'est tout s'organise
dans ses 80 mètres carrés très
encombrées le quartier général de
l'association ac les rôles sont bien
répartis
christophe aguiton l'ancien touristes
supervise les occupations de locaux
claire villiers qui a fait ses premières
armes dans les jeunesses ouvrières
chrétiennes se chargent des
manifestations moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
parce que je sois content et c'est bien
pour garder le contrôle du mouvement que
claire vignier se rend dans les locaux
occupés de la capitale depuis trois
jours 50 manifestants ont envahi l'école
normale supérieure
peu de chômeurs sur le toit mais
beaucoup de jeunes militants parfois
tentés d'en découdre avec des forces de
l'ordre omniprésentes
ah non mais je veux dire pas les
bouteilles et rue comme celle ci on peut
visiter ces lieux où on n'a pas commencé
comme bonjour au niveau des images sont
restés de dire le fait d'occuper et de
sueur bouger sans arrêt un peu comme le
sparadrap du capitaine haddock d'avancé
jamais où ils vont aller avec qui
gouverne pas tous riches ont toujours
visibles
vous avez une improvisation de plus en
plus difficile à gérer à mesure que le
mouvement s'étend aux familles pour
qu'elles mais je saute alors que les
flics quand un lieu on a décidé
d'occuper pour faire émerger des luttes
et vous voulez faire la paix sociale et
la légion parce que vous contrôlez plus
tellement le mois là c'est qu'ils ne
veulent pas sortir lui va bien tu
rentres pas que les flics tous les jours
enfin pas le temps de s'attarder claire
vignier encore beaucoup de problèmes à
régler pour la manifestation de samedi
au faux pas c'est modifier au delà de la
cgt en lutte il faut sept ans drôle
claire villiers l'aveu pour une raison
bien précise la cfdt c'est son syndicat
depuis plus de 20 ans elle y militent
dans une fraction résolument hostile à
nicole notât